one thing you're gonna be contending
with and you're gonna see it tonight too
is I brought my entire not the whole
staff but as many people as everybody
wanted to go but we could only bring a
select group we brought him everybody
was weepy after the film and I'm the guy
that's usually giving them a hard time
because we'll go see a film to get ready
for the show and I'm the guy that
doesn't cry and I was there's some stuff
in there about brothers yeah really got
to me Sam Elliot is just my God and
there and and there's I just I was
getting yeah and and you guys have this
and there is a scene that really got to
me and I'm like this is happening to me
I know that's curious does this is this
do you cry it films you cry when you're
watching TV what gets to you
I do cries I gotten older I remember my
father as he I never saw him cry when I
grew up it was like you never cry and
and then as my father got older he
started crying at everything and and
that's starting to happen to me I cry I
cry a lot I cry I cry movies yeah I like
crying a movies yeah but you don't cry
much I don't cry that much but every now
and then it takes me by surprise yeah
yeah yeah yeah I do Andy Andy cries
through most of the interviews he's
always over there just weeping chopping
onion now do you think now I'm a
horrible crier too like I'm an ugly
crier it's not like one tear it's like
some weird distorted face then you know
it's bred in the veins and yeah yeah
it's not good look like you're turning
into the Hulk yeah yeah do you cry
publicly like if you're on a plane will
you cry I mean it would be like this you
know I mean it'll be you know be like be
private I mean don't you cry on planes I
don't know if it's the oxygen but I find
myself crying a lot watching movies on
like random movies and like a reason to
cry there's all kinds of stuff you can
blame on low oxygen
I'll even that's true that's why I
attack the people around me
you